Narrator: These Lucchese gator boots
have been worn for about 10 years.
The friction of wear has created a hole
in the toe area.
They will be restored by Unsung House,
a Tennessee shoe-repair shop
that specializes in
restoring cowboy boots.
A cobbler removes the
heel block and outsole
using nipper pliers
and a round-point leatherworking knife.
Then he cuts off the boot's gemming,
since it will be replaced later.
He patches the hole in the boot's toe area
using a special glue
and a piece of leather,
which he sands to comfortably
blend into the shoe.
A new gemming is glued on.
Then he sews it in for added security.
A new leather welt goes over the gemming.
This creates a layer to attach
the uppers to the outsole.
The cobbler then cuts, glues,
and hammers in new cork midsoles.
The cork is grated,
glued,
and attached to the new outsole.
He uses two machines
to finish the outsole.
One cuts the excess sole,
and another sews a Goodyear welt.
Then the soles are sanded and dyed.
To finish the restoration,
he attaches the heel
block with glue and nails.
Once the heels are dyed
to match the rest of the sole,
the boots are given a final polish.
After a year of heavy wear,
these Birkenstock soles have worn out,
exposing the cork footbed
and causing serious damage.
To repair them, Rio Kim starts
by removing the foam outsole with a knife.
He cuts, rather than
peels, the soles apart
to avoid damaging the
cork footbed further.
He applies glue in the crevice
of the cracked cork
and squeezes the joints together
for one minute, while the glue dries.
For the shoe with the damaged heel,
Rio trims cork footboard to fit the area,
then secures it with glue.
He shapes the cork with a sander
and 40-grit sandpaper.
Then he uses the old outsole
to create a pattern for the new ones
and roughly cuts them out.
Rio sands the foam outsoles
and bottoms of the shoes
to even out the surface.
This creates a clean canvas
and helps the glue stick.
He applies glue to the shoe bottom
and the foam outsole,
then bends the outsole
so it fits the curved footbed comfortably.
The body of the shoes and outsole
are then pressed together,
and Rio cuts the excess off.
The last step is sanding the sole to shape
and applying sealant to the cork footbeds.
These well-loved LLBean boots
are now torn between the sole and upper.
They were mailed back
to the LLBean factory
for resoling.
A special machine deconstructs the boots
by sawing the outsoles
apart from the uppers.
A technician then strips the boots
of the remaining brush guard
using scissors and a flat knife.
The remaining stitches
will be individually plucked
off the uppers by hand.
A rub machine with rotating bristles
loosens the stitches
and makes the work easier.
With the stitches removed,
the boots can be reassembled.
Cement is applied to the boot's new sole
and the upper,
then the soles and uppers are attached.
To finish, a vamping machine
drops three rows of stitches
to secure the uppers to the sole.
After these Louboutin loafers
were worn in the rain,
the paint at the bottom bubbled.
To restore the trademark red bottoms,
Sunny applies a rubber protective sole.
He starts by deciding
where the new protective soles
and original soles will meet.
He tapes a guide, then uses a knife
to skive an end joint.
This is where the new
thicker protective sole
will blend into the original.
He follows the same process
on the shoe's heels.
Then he sands the soles and heels
to remove their paint
and even out the surface.
Sunny applies glue to
the bottom of the shoe
and the new protective soles.
The soles and shoe body
are then pressed together.
He trims the excess sole,
then sands it to the shape of the shoe.
To finish, he dresses the edges
and polishes the shoe.
These Air Jordan 11s are from 1996
and have yellowed with age.
To repair the discoloration,
Richard Brown deconstructs the shoe.
He peels the soles apart
from one another by hand.
When the outsoles are removed,
he separates the midsole
from the upper of the shoe.
He deoxidizes the outsoles
using ultraviolet light
and 40-volume creme, a gel lightener.
This repairs the soles' yellowing.
Then he removes old glue from the outsole,
midsole, and bottom of the shoe
using a rotary tool and acetone.
The outsoles, midsoles, and uppers
are reattached using a special glue
formulated for sneaker repair.